running marathons going to work
building relationships you choose no
one's forcing you
and we need to get comfortable with that
we need to embrace that we need to
acknowledge that everyone's like i have
to go to work
no you don't you have to go to work in a
number of scenarios
because at the end of the month you get
what's called a paycheck which then gets
you the
car that you like and
that car is feeding into your
insecurities it's giving you temporary
happiness
and it's giving you temporary happiness
because it's it's numbing
a block that you're not willing to
address which could come
from a previous subconscious behavior
you don't have to go to work tomorrow
nobody has to go to work tomorrow you
choose to
so when i'm in trouble i chose to be
here
ladies and gentlemen welcome back i'm
joined by the one and only marcus smith
how are you brother thank you very much
how can i not be good right here right
now
it's not a bad background wait is this i
don't know if this clash is
a working holiday for you but uh those
yeah
if you're watching anyway yeah exactly
tune in on youtube on the 25th floor of
dubai marina
overlooking a backdrop that yeah it
could be like it's epic
it's pretty epic it's pretty good right
joe rogan never heard of her
so i've been doing my research a lot
since i've been out here knowing i was
going to record with you
and you just continually do mad [ __ ]
you closet psychopath what are you
working on at the moment what's
next interesting because sometimes we
start
where did this all start you've gone
straight into what's next which i quite
like because
next is a we're actually going to run
mate and
this is quite interesting because
obviously this year has been mental for
absolutely everyone
and we've seen a lot of people naturally
get frustrated that events are canceled
travels cancelled and a lot of people
have literally just thrown their hands
up in the air
like this and done nothing put on weight
motivation has gone down and it's
terrible on a number of levels
we were like well we know we're not
going to travel this year
and this year i would have run probably
about three
ultras in different countries around the
world
and so what we did is we looked at the
map of the uae
and i think this is actually the first
time i've said this to
our classy as a media mate to the media
um we looked at the map of the uae and i
was like
okay what's the challenging parts of the
uae
and lots of people think dubai in the
uae is what we see
around us now which is mourinho it's
very beautiful but there's actually a
high point of the uae which is just
about
2 000 meters in the mountains and
there's a mountain range that
divides the east coast and the west
coast called the hajjar mountains and i
thought to myself it'd be really
interesting
if we could sort of traverse
that mountain range and then
take it take a turn inland and end up at
my gym
and i sort of said and this is how these
things start like
like you know there's a couple of mates
and we'll get on google maps and we'll
just
draw on our phones and just send
different things to each other
it's almost like a gamble or a guessing
game how far is it
and one of the boys goes oh i think
that's about 250.
i said yeah i think it's a bit longer i
think it's about 300.
anyway so we got this idea and then
and this is honestly like how it starts
is then one of the lads goes
or the boy i was sending it to rob he
goes when are we doing it
and so this is how these challenges kind
of start
a lot of the time mate and you know it's
some people it's like the way that you
guys going about endurance events
yeah is how normal people talk about
going out for dinner
yeah can i not just so have you heard
about that new place yeah just
good sushi the seafood's really nice you
guys
look on google maps like the trip
advisor of suffering
yeah and you're like yeah that one looks
like it could really [ __ ] us up let's do
that yeah let's do that and that's
that's kind of what it was and we're
like we've got to finish the year strong
we gotta
make it count and and we've got to we
have a
i consider that we have an incredible
responsibility to the people and
something i take quite seriously to
to set an example people need to come
into
an environment and have people that they
look up to that are doing good things
and
i take that very very seriously and very
very personally as well that
i should always be raising the bar for
myself
and for other people it is quite selfish
in a way that i want to explore my
potential
but in doing so i want to let make
people think actually what is
what's my potential and we're all
climbing a different everest
if you want a cliched way of looking at
it so if someone can look and go well
these idiots are going to do this
then i can do this so yeah mate transit
the question
we're going to run 300 kilometers it is
300 kilometers
from the highest point of the uae it's
200 kilometers
through the hajja mountain range which
is about 6 000 meters of elevation
and then we're going to take a hard
right turn
and then the last hundred kilometers is
across desert
and that will take us to to to my gym to
inner fight
and the initial plan this is kind of
where the whole
year has just been amazing for timelines
and when we talk about
goals you know anyone that uses the
smart principle it has to be
time related you know and i was training
a few weeks ago and i was descending and
and my knees sort of came across a
problem with my knee let's put it that
way like a sharp knife going through my
knee
and so now the day that we were going to
complete that challenge is obviously not
realistic anymore it doesn't work and i
sat down with rob and
actually i think we did it over whatsapp
and i said listen mate if you want to
continue the challenge without me
i'm there i'll ride a bike next to you
i'll drive a car as much as i can next
to you and he's like mate
time's not a problem we'll wait and
we'll do it as soon as you're ready
so hopefully by the end of the year mate
we'll be the first piece
people to which is quite important for
certain
reasons we'll be the first people to
sort of transcend the
the hajjar mountain range 300 kilometers
and hopefully we'll get it done
in just over two days so really so what
will you do do you aim to have little
breath stuff if you plan that yeah yeah
so the way that we look at it
is that we we'd go for about six hours
and we try and complete
about a marathon every six hours and
then
we would rest and feed which would take
anywhere
90 minutes up to two hours also what we
also it's important to understand that
although
these races and these challenges are
races you need to respect your
your body and your mind and we always
try and buffer
on the edge if we push like we could go
24 hours straight
we've both done more than that before
but then we might fall off the end so
we're looking at sort of six on
two off and we'd get through it we think
we'd get through it in just over two
days
so i mean it's easy to say you've got
those two hours and you sleep but mate
with adrenaline and i've been in races
before and it's like okay it's rest time
now and try and lay down and your
heart's just gone
i was gonna say what does that feel like
obviously you know that you have this
small window in which to do
the recovery and you're there and you
can't get yourself everyone that's
listening knows what it's like to
try and get to sleep i need to be up
early tomorrow the difference is you
need to be up and start running yeah
it's like it's savage and it's uh it's
it's a mindset thing though as well like
there's two things going on there's the
actual
chemical reactions in your body what
your dopamine is doing your melatonin's
all over the place your cortisols
through the roof like
that's that's real so it's not like i
can't sleep
like you can't sleep so you got to sort
of deal with that but you also
it's almost like how can i frame this if
you
if you're scared of flying and you've
got flight the next day
you don't sleep and i'm sure you don't
sleep or if you're scared of anything
that's coming up
it's the same thing because after six
hours six hours in we'll have run
40 to 50k we still have 250 kilometers
to go
this part is a complete mindset the
physiological side
what's happening in your in your brain
neurologically you
that is normal but the mindset of how to
control
be it anxiety and to stay cool that's
something you can actually train mate
and for my first race till now
now it's it's not that difficult like
i've done stuff
i trained a little bit for for what they
call backyard ultra which is 6.7 k's
on the hour every hour for as long as we
can go
and i trained that one night on my own
out here in the desert for
12 hours and the first two hours was
pretty [ __ ] because i i didn't know how
to behave
but after that mate i'd come in at about
40 to 45 minutes
quickly drink something eat something
and then just get
into literally mate into shavasana
position from yoga
and just breathe alarm would go off at
two minutes to the hour
shoes were already on stand up drink
some water and go
and i trained that for 10 hours so now
coming into that relaxed state
actually becomes easier and i think if
people can take anything from
from what i've learned is we have to
train these things
like they don't just happen you have to
i had
12 hours that night training it a lot of
people
want to want to be able to do stuff be
it related to mental resilience
a number of different areas of life and
they're not willing to spend that time
in like experimentation if you want to
say
and and and with that a little bit
discomfort as well
you know i've been thinking a lot this
year about mental masturbation
yeah everybody everyone this year has
had far too much time to think and far
too little time to do
yes and a lot of that has been outside
of our control
gyms have been closed if your gym is
closed and you don't have weights at
home you're restricted you're stuck to
yeah
[ __ ] everyone's sick of burpees in
2020
but what that causes and
all of us that listen to podcasts and
consume audio books and read and stuff
like that
we can end up being so cerebral that we
forget
that the implementation is where the
work happens yes
it's important to know what you need to
do because if you don't know what you
need to do when you go to do it yeah
you're just
kind of flopping around yeah but you
need to go and do it
you have to do mate 100 like you ask
anyone who's listening to this show how
many books
podcasts youtube videos etc etc
have you tuned in to have you learned
from
in 2020 versus 2019 2018
you're probably up two or three hundred
percent
how much action have you taken with the
knowledge that you have
you're probably down a thousand percent
so we've got all of this knowledge now
we've got all these thoughts going along
and we're making excuses that we can't
do
you can still do if you read in
in what's one of the big books that i've
read this year
ross edgeley the art of resilience
throughout residence incredible guy
there's a lot of learnings in that but
there's a lot of stuff
that you can implement on a daily basis
like
really how does your and i was talking
to a guy the other day
who was having problems with essentially
with with
rejection and self-confidence so he gets
scared when he's coming to teach
we're coming into contact with people to
talk with people i was like
how often outside of those situations
are you actually training that
you know man i love to create like just
like
scenarios and i was like well i wonder
if a way to overcome that would be
to go and run down the beach track one
morning and
force yourself to make eye contact with
and say hello
to absolutely every person you see
it's quite a sick sort of trick isn't it
but
if you've got confidence issues at the
beach track in the morning you might see
200 people
guaranteed 100 people are going to
reject you
either because they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
or because they're just in their zone
and i respect that mate not everyone
says hello
i always abuse someone i don't but
that's do you know what i mean and i'm
like
we can create these scenarios
to do with all this knowledge that we've
learned
but we have to be committed and they're
doing it's easy to read
and to get excited and for dopamine to
be released in our brain
and and literally mate is masturbation
like we've got a [ __ ] boner
oh it's so exciting i'm not sure what we
can say on this channel
but still we're super excited about it
but let's go out and do
like let's let's keep on the
masturbation side let's stop reading the
porno
and let's call the girl up and go on a
date you know
this is your resonates with people
myself analogy everyone can listen can
understand from 2020 i think yeah
absolutely
it's been good for a lot of things but
bad for sex good for mustaches
good for podcasts but terrible for
partnerships and
a couple of years ago you had a huge
accident broke a bunch of ribs punctured
alone
pulled your scapular off and you said it
was part of one of the best years of
your life yeah
how how does that work how does that fit
in
yeah it's interesting three i guess
three things three big things happened
in 2018
that are i believe that moments in our
life obviously define us and when i look
back at 2018
three really big things happen maybe
four which if you kick it off on the 9th
of february
and and this is totally legit you can't
change this
go back to my instagram mjd underscore
smith 19th of february i posted a quote
said everything happens for a reason
10th of february at about 4 to 8 in the
morning i nearly lose my life
wild three days in intensive care five
days in hospital injuries that you just
said
and when i was in that hospital bed i
thought to myself
if you can't ride a bike what can you do
an answer is run and i i have quite a
decent background i've run a lot
in running and i was like well i'll run
and i read dean carnassus book
50 marathons in 50 states in 50 days in
i think it was may or june time and then
i made a decision that
in line with my fitness challenge of
2018 which is a 30-day fitness challenge
here in dubai
i'd run 30 marathons in 30 days and i
was like what a better way
to to to come back from it so i've
crashed
and then i've proven that you can
recover
and then about a week after i finished
on the 24th of november i finished and
on the 5th of december was my 40th
birthday
like how can that not be the best year
of your life you know
i mean the crush the crash to most
people would seem like something that
would be a huge setback
and it would why don't i well because
you've gone from someone who is capable
who had these plans
for ultra bike races in a year
across different countries and that's
now stopped
and when we go from one world to another
often that's perceived as a challenge or
a bad thing but yeah and that's i wanna
like
the word you just use there is super
important
it's perceived and we're living a lot on
perception
perceptions and thoughts that we create
based on the opinions of others
a lot of the time we've been told that
those things are bad
and this relationship is always bad i'm
i'm not in a good place and mentally we
make i still have it don't get me wrong
i'm not not bulletproof from it
the first few days after i back on my
knee
i was not in a good place mate and we
know what goes with it
relationship i'm not having a good time
with my wife in those days
you know at work it's just too much
we're not
but this is because this in my opinion
it's a subconscious behavior
that we've been drilled into us around
perception because we're told
guys [ __ ] happens things happen for a
reason
and even when things happen we can't
change them because they've already
happened
but perception says it
sends us backwards come on
2018 i learnt [ __ ] that i would have
never learned
i had tough times mate don't get me
wrong i [ __ ]
like i was like why is this happening to
me
you know i'm bulletproof but then you
look at it and you go this is the way
it's supposed to be
and that's when we have to embrace this
stuff otherwise yeah we see it as
regret we see a setback and we get asked
this
a lot like what do you regret the most
in your life
[ __ ] off nothing because if i regret
i'm holding on to these things mate so
it's easy to sit here and say that and
we're almost
reading the porno where we should be
having sex but you've been you've you've
been there this is you post quietly this
is the pillow talk from you right
this is going to go through the whole
show yeah absolutely it's a common
thread welcome to the porno pocket
yeah so a big part of that is the fact
that you've been there
and proven it um and i think that that's
the difference between hearing a
motivational speaker
and hearing someone who has been forged
in battle
yeah talking about their experience
that's why it resonates with people so
much more
yeah um so just want to go back just a
little bit you had this
accident you're laying there i just want
to go through kind of
what's in your mind because hearing this
yeah and
hearing you where you are now with this
these lessons that you've taken away
this mental resilience yeah
it's hard for people to believe that
this guy
could ever have a negative thought could
ever feel like things are going badly
yeah yeah he just bounces off stuff like
like a rubber ball
yeah so what goes through your mind
when you hit by a truck what goes
through your mind when you
laid up in hospital and you don't know
what your recovery is going to be like
yeah can we just talk about them yeah
yeah i and the example is really or the
reality it's not an example it's what
happened
so i wake up in in icu and
make icu is pretty rough like
it's the icu i was in was just curtains
not separate rooms so literally
the guy next to me is dying like he's
he's dying mate
and i'm trying not to die
like it's pretty [ __ ] up so i'm laying
in this bed and you've got
i've got oxygen going in through my nose
and it's uncomfortable because you've
got these things up your nose and
they've just put uh
they've just put a tube into my lungs to
drain the blood off
and i've got catheter in and you like
you've got different bits and then a
machine up here that's just beeping your
pulse
and i'm like you know can you turn it
off they're like no i'm like why not and
then
like because then we won't know you're
dead or alive and it's brutal mate
and and you're drugged up which is the
only good thing because
you need those drugs to take away the
pain
and so you're on and off sleepy
and i remember waking up late and
i was i was in a low
point it was awful i was i was really
i think to the easiest way to explain it
was i was
i was playing the victim mindset i was
like why is this happen to me
what if it was different and i
may we'd ridden the route before
and every time we'd ride this route we'd
stop at petrol station
it'd be about an hour to the petrol
station lads would have a coffee bit of
banter and then we carry on the way
we pull into the petrol station on this
day
myron lads who wants a coffee no one
wants a coffee
it's okay don't worry so we just get
some water and we go
obviously man if we would have had a
coffee the truck would have been there
it would have already gone on
i said if there's one like what's the
biggest learning
always have always happened
you know what i mean and i'm there mate
and
i'm i'm really just thinking all these
thoughts and i'm like
what if why me i just wish it wasn't
happening
and holly was laid there was sat at the
side of my bed
and i could see she could see some
discomfort in my face and she said
what's wrong with you
and i tried to i sort of started
explaining you know
why me and she looked at me mate
and she says i'm not emotional enough
and i say that she's too emotional but
literally
in this scenario she was flipped 180
and she just looked straight at me and
she said
it happened literally heartbroken
oh my god the one time i wanted some
sympathy
and she she just sat there mate she
didn't cry
she nothing and she said it happened
it's like literally someone's just
taking the wind out my sails
and i sort of just i didn't react and i
laid there
i was like she's [ __ ] right
and then i went a little bit back to
sleep with this thought
and i think it was that point where i
just
accepted and acceptance is hard
you break a leg to accept that you've
broken your leg and you can't walk for a
time
your relationship breaks to accept that
you're going to be on your own you're
going to have to
it's awful now but we have to go through
it it's part of the healing process
and it's it's what i call the ultra
mindset
is that a lot of the time our first
point is denial
didn't happen this relationship's fine
no it's not do you know what i mean i
couldn't keep myself mate i was laid
directly across the bed i had these
tubes coming out for me
i could hardly breathe i couldn't move
my hand like
i can't say i'm not here so the first
step is we have to admit that there's a
problem and her saying that
got me out of that victim mindset and
it was funny because i sort of probably
went back to sleep and then i woke up
and i looked at her
and i smiled and she's like what's wrong
with you
i said i you're right i said you know
what i'm gonna do
she's like what i said i'm gonna start
training
she's looking at me i don't know she
wanted to cry maybe she was laughing or
or what was going on
and i looked down at my body and i think
they'd cut my cycling kit which
hurt my soul favorite cycle again you
know they're cutting through it
i think i still had my cycling shorts on
but they'd cut all the bit bit off
and literally mate i'm laying like this
and i put my hand on the table and
looked at this hand my whole left side
of my body is [ __ ] broken
and i just went i just said what can i
do right now
and honestly mate with everything
i had i just turned this hand
like this and i was so emotional
but i couldn't cry i'm not i'm not a
very good crier mate
long story but i was just like
amazing and i've got it to hear
and then i'm like i think i'm [ __ ] a
dog with two dicks i've gone
i don't know if i can get it back
[Laughter]
and everything is reset and i've done it
once
and then of course i'm like okay i can
do it once i can do it ten times
literally mate and that took me about
five minutes and
i don't know physically i was drained
but
mentally emotionally everything else in
my body was completely drained i was
crying without tears
because i knew that that was the point
where i'd started my recovery
because i knew admitting to holly and
her being that cold with me and that
honest with me
that it happened had
let me get out of denial and admit the
problem
and now i can start to recover so what
are the principles that you've taken
away from that the radical acceptance of
things that have happened
understanding that you can't change the
past yes that's number one
focusing on what you can do to improve
your future yeah
what else i mean and that's that's the
process
that that we go through admit that
there's a problem
then you sort of you you reject that
that
problem is going to stop you from from
achieving what you want to achieve in
life
these things are going to happen mate
right now i can't run that's fine i
snapped an achilles three months ago
same thing you know but look at the
energy that you're putting into the
podcast for example
so then we we reject the fact that it's
going to stop us
then and it's the hardest thing like
just relax
we can't you know how many times when
we're kids
do our parents just send us to the room
calm down for 10 minutes
ah hey you're banging the door down
you're having a fit just calm down for
10 minutes
so the third point is you have to relax
and then the fourth point the most
important point is what i did and how i
explained it with my hand there is what
can
i do right now to make this situation
better there is always
something you can do in some scenarios
if you and i are having an argument and
we're just about to blow
sometimes what i can do right now to
make the situation better for both of us
is just to walk away from you that
doesn't feel like
that doesn't feel like it's going
towards the goal and this is the problem
because we're
told all the time that you've got to
keep tracking it up you've got to keep
moving forward you've got to get closer
to your goal
every day is a day to win but that
doesn't and
it's true but it doesn't mean that we
have to be going
this way the path's not necessarily
linear it's not linear right
life's not [ __ ] linear what you can
do right now
is what your parents tell you go to your
room
sit down relax you know so
honestly mate they're the four key
things that i
i take away from it admit that there's a
problem reject the fact that it's going
to stop you from getting
what you want stay relaxed and figure
out what you can do right now
and what you can do right now sometimes
is and
i've said it before when when i speak
about my ultra races
sometimes i have to sit under a tree for
five minutes and let the competition fly
past
because i'm on that red line and if i
keep going i'm gonna go over that red
line
you sit under the tree for five minutes
and later that day
you go sailing past them if you don't
they'll beat you every time
it's the hardest thing to do it's a very
tricky
way to look at things to either go back
because society
perception tells us we've always got to
go forward
but in going back you're going forward
and that's really important
one of the things that i'm fascinated by
is maintaining motivation outside
of situations like that so during that
period
when you're just coming off an accident
you're just coming out of an incident
everyone will know that it's the new
year's day motivation right
we just had this the emotions are high
i'm compelled i've
filled myself full of all the stoicism
and ross edgely that i can and i feel
like i'm able to get over this
how are you ensuring that you don't
start to lose motivation in the in the
messy middle that you hit that valley of
despair when the motivation and the
energy starts to dip
and for me this is a personal question
i'm at three and a half months post-op
now on my achilles the it's the
most drudge work boring consistent
everyday heel raises every day
stretching it's
painful it hurts every step that i take
every step i'm reminded that i snap my
achilles
every single time that i want to walk i
can't move as quick as my friends i
can't
i tried to hop across a street yesterday
in dubai and
i haven't tried to move quicker than a
walk and i realized that i had to do
this weird like heel hop thing
where because i've got no i've still got
no tension in my achilles and i'm like
every single day
this sucks this sucks three and a half
months in and this is that value of
despair how are you
continuing your recovery and also how
long was the recovery to get yourself
back to full fitness
from your access super good questions is
that there's a there's a lot going on
and a few different answers mate
the number one thing i want to share is
a lot of people say oh you recovered
super fast
i'm like no i didn't you never saw
the 10 000 reps i did like this
all the 5 000 reps i did like that
you never saw it i spent hours
and we all spend hours i feel your pain
my achilles heel races
the whole thing it's brutal how do you
maintain that
one of the let's talk about what tools
we have right now
smartphones we're non-stop taking
selfies
i often look back to the pictures
that i have on my camera reel of when i
was in hospital
when i was in intensive care
at my lowest point and then i'll take a
selfie
on that day and you see the difference
in your face
your body language it's incredible name
we're not
taking enough what i would call
inventory
of where we're at on a number of levels
you
three months ago three and a half months
ago when you snapped your achilles
you couldn't walk when i walked in here
today
you came up to the door you
lunged forward towards me you're on your
toes
and we embraced that takes an incredible
amount of power for the achilles
you're in an incredible position mate
but
we feel the pain the whole time it's
almost there to remind us
but what's that pain there to remind us
relax just today we're only going to
this level
we're not going to run again people get
down
because they're not tracking their
process their progress they're not
taking inventory
flip back through your camera roll of
what you could do
what you can do now how your face looks
how your body language looks
it's all there it really is all there
we're not using technology i love it and
hate it mate
we're able to sit here now have this
conversation in a few days time
people around the world are able to go
through their walk through the marina
and listen to us talking [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] brilliant and we use it
for that but when we're in a hole we
don't use it
there's gonna be dark times
14 16 weeks not able to walk properly
pain in your achilles is a nightmare
especially the achilles because it
does everything you know i just let me
get this pot out
i can't you know you just there's so
many things you just can't do it's like
a calf injury it's awful
so we we're constantly reminded
about the negative side of it that again
feeds into our subconscious
and makes us think that we're not doing
well we're not progressing
spend time each day feeding your
subconscious
not [ __ ] and this is the difference
lots of people say i'm okay i'm getting
better i'm getting
i've lost one gram this week i'm really
in good shape no you're still a fat [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it just it's
not like that when we need to [ __ ]
ourselves
but we need to keep feeding our
subconscious
the positive things as well because
there's a lot
we need to celebrate the small victories
like literally mate the day that i could
bring my
hand to parallel to eye level
was just incredible so who are you
celebrating with
are you celebrating with yourself is it
important to share this with other
people yeah
i me i celebrate a lot with myself
which sounds a little bit [ __ ] up
doesn't it like because
i think for me personally a lot of time
i don't think people can understand it
not because i'm special or but there's
no one
that's inside my head except me
sometimes i'll celebrate i i'll tell
holly i'm super excited
about something but without
sounding nasty to polly she can't
connect with that thing
like i try and explain what i feel when
i when i run 10k or when i run 100k
it doesn't resonate with her so you're
not gonna and this hurts us as well
we're not gonna get a positive reception
from someone who doesn't understand it
just doesn't happen
you have to pick the people in your life
that understand you
who understands you i have a few people
mate i have a few
mentors that i've developed over time or
just
incredibly good friends i don't have
many friends
i'll be honest i know a [ __ ] ton of
people there's not many people that
not because i don't want to develop
friendships
but that i just don't feel understand me
in a certain way i've got this
quote from alanda bottom the guy behind
the school of life and he says
loneliness is a kind of tax that we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind
yeah and it's my favorite video why
we're fated to be lonely
and that's natural no one looks at the
things that you do physically
and presumes that you are a normal
representation
of a human because not many people run
30 marathons in 30 days you decide to
do the stuff that you do and yet when we
hear that someone like that non-typical
physically yeah
is non-typical socially
maybe struggles to find people with whom
they can connect
yeah that doesn't necessarily click
straight away but it should make sense
yeah loneliness is a kind of tax we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind
yeah and the more extraordinary you are
the fewer people are like you yeah um
given the choice between honesty and
acceptability a lot of people choose the
latter
a lot of people will choose to nerf the
edges of the way that they operate the
way that they think
and that feeds us back into what you
were talking about before that we
we absorb our values
and our desires and our operating
procedures
from society from the people around us
and that really rids us
of what makes us special yeah you are
you are a very unique combination of
your genetics your past traumas your
paths of least resistance the way that
you
speak the way that you move the fact
that when you do a snatch your right arm
doesn't go as far back as your left you
know all of the individual things that
make up the uniqueness that is you
yes and i
am a huge champion of people trying to
embrace their weirdness
like stay weird yeah is the most
the single most powerful phrase that
i've heard over the last few years
yeah it reminds us that our uniqueness
is our competitive advantage
um and yeah i think that it's
interesting for people to hear that
looking from the outside in this guy who
owns a gym you know thousands of people
tens of thousands of people in dubai you
will have seen him you're on the side of
the burj khalifa running up the side of
the world's tallest building
not physically um in a crop top
in a crop top yeah exactly um and yeah
there's challenges with making
connection with people
because the price that you have to pay
in order for that level of performance
is this slight disconnect
and again this is something else i've
been talking about a lot this year what
is the price that you have to pay to be
that person what's the price you have to
pay to be elon musk
like everyone looks at him and thinks
unbelievably productive guy running
tesla getting us to mars doing all of
this stuff
but you don't know what elon musk's
relationship with his body is like
maybe he hates what he sees in the
mirror maybe he's not had an erection in
years
maybe he can't uh he doesn't have a
relationship with his father do you want
to pay that price
to be elon musk conor mcgregor everyone
looks at him ubiquitous success
yeah but do you want to live in your
parents attic for six years
rolling the same sequences throwing the
same combinations with them
on job seekers allowance with no
promise of success at the end of it do
you want that life because that's the
price you have to pay to be in
yeah and i think
because we only get to see the highlight
reel yeah
of most people's lives and even when
people decide to post the open and
honest insights into their lives they
don't get as much
exposure yeah as their successes do yeah
inevitably we presume that people live
in these highlight reels
where actually it's just front row seat
failure
as you fall from like mistake to mistake
and and hearing insights like that i
think are really really important
because it reminds us that even the
people we think are superhuman
have their weaknesses and their
vulnerabilities
and their failings that
we might not have yes you know yeah and
it's totally true what you're saying
because i'll wake up some mornings
and we all get it mate i'm just not
feeling it
i'm just not feeling it you know but
when you have a decision-making process
and i think this is the biggest thing
that's lacking we're all
humans we all have a lot of the same
feelings and emotions we go through ups
we go
wake up we're not feeling it not every
day mate
do i feel like going out and doing my
training i have the same
thoughts that you have that someone
who's
you know feels like they're at what
bottom we have it
but we've narrowed the choices
because for example my decision-making
process when my alarm goes off
is to get up i don't have a choice at
that time
if i wake up and i'm feeling like [ __ ]
there's only still one choice get up
if i've planned a training session
there's only one choice
do it unless there's a real reason why i
shouldn't obviously
the day after so that unless
that is the point at which get up
unless and the tolerance that people
have for that yes
is where the rubber meets the road with
this stuff absolutely mate and
that's the problem is that you know i'll
set my alarm for
seven in the morning and if i wake up
and i feel okay i'll probably go to the
gym
like come on you're never gonna go like
you know you're not gonna go
whereas i'll set my alarm for 5 59
because i'm going to get out of bed i'm
going to put my trainers on i'm going to
go for a walk
we've suddenly changed the whole world
if you don't feel great when you wake up
that's okay
it's fine it's normal there has to be
brene brown talks about it has to be
this vulnerability mate
i go through lows but when i'm in that
low
the option is or the goal is is to make
that
trough as small as possible
i've got clients and we've all known
people that have been off
for two weeks just not feeling
themselves
far out what have you done about it
nothing yet how long have you been
feeling like this a month
what so you've tolerated
waking up every morning for a month
feeling like [ __ ]
yeah i thought it was going to get
better it doesn't get better
and this is where we have to understand
we all go through it
but i think people that what you use
bounce back
just identify it go back to what we were
saying earlier
admit it i'm feeling [ __ ] now there's
nothing wrong
i feel like [ __ ] there is something
wrong we admit that there's a problem
let's go for a walk and let's see what
happens is it my mind is it my thoughts
is it physically do we scan our body
do we take a morning naked the
bathroom mirror selfie back to the phone
what are the best things mate to track
your progress
make your bathroom mirror selfie please
make sure your
icloud is not linked this is one of
those huge uh
huge data breaches that ends up
happening with marcus smith's news leaks
on the internet
but we have to have this decision making
process
if anyone thinks that elon's not having
a bad day
if anyone thinks that i can sit and talk
about motivation and i
because i run you're making an excuse
for yourself
we're all going through tough times it's
not easy
but that decision-making process and our
tolerance of how long we're going to be
in a bad mood
is totally our choice and we've got to
have
but we also have to train it and not
everything you try
will work on every situation it's like
being a handyman and only having a
hammer
you know i know that's a [ __ ] cliche but
really
that's the thing and you've learned
we've said it you've learned all these
tools in 2020 we've read more books
listened to more podcasts than
ever before try some of those tools
don't just we we're pretty quick to
accept
and i think that sucks because we accept
that
feeling [ __ ] is part of life it is
but it should only be a small part is is
our objective
there's a thing that marcus aurelius
used to do called the equanimity game
yeah
and he used to imagine falling off a
horse and it was a game to get back on
and increasingly like life is a game is
something that continues to come back
i really do i haven't quite worked out
why i love it so much
but i think it just reminds us that a
lot of the challenges that we're coming
up against
will in some future point just be a
memory
they'll just be like an instant replay
that we can go back to in our mind
like a perfect example of this was after
i had
my operation um some of the opiates that
i was put on
caused stomach inflammation so for about
three days
after my op i was unable to sleep unable
to eat
was laid up in bed with my foot on a big
wedge
just in constant seven out of ten pain
couldn't do anything
like for three days straight no one
could take the pain away
yeah i'd stopped taking the oral
morphine the codeine the paracetamol the
ibuprofen
because i wanted the stomach pain to
stop which meant that my ankle now
only a couple of days post-op was that
pain was through the roof
and i was doing all of this with one leg
so when i needed to go to the bathroom
to not do
anything i was hopping there i was
having to use crutches i was in the dark
i was feeling miserable
i was on my own mum and dad would come
and see me on my housemate to come see
me or my friends would come see
they can't do anything they can't take
it away and at the time
it feels like a existential curse
that's been given just to you that this
is your pain this is your suffering to
bear
and now when i look back it's just a
story i tell on a podcast
and i'm like me then would hate
hearing me now being so flippant about
it it's like no it was really it was it
was bad
you're not forgetting how bad it was and
i'm like no no it's not about that and
trying to put ourselves into that
third-party perspective i think like
treating life as the equanimity game how
quickly can i get back on the horse okay
like i'm inevitably going to fall off of
course yeah how quickly can i get back
on i think that that's a really nice way
for us to frame it and
i'm a big fan of maxim's and pithy
statements because i think that they
they spearhead big concepts that would
take us
10 minutes to remind ourselves into
just little aphorisms are there any of
the things
you're going through an event you're
suffering you're deep in the hole
what are the things during that time
that you remind yourself of are there
certain phrases and aphorisms or
concepts that you rely on to keep going
you know i've been asked this a lot
recently
i don't know i don't know why so i
better check more thoughts about it but
one of the things that i think of the
most
is you chose to be here
i choose what i'm doing no one's got a
gun at my head
and when you think about it
we have now more than ever
an insane amount of choice
and running marathons
going to work building relationships
you choose no one's forcing you
and we need to get comfortable with that
we need to embrace that we need to
acknowledge that
everyone's like have to go to work no
you don't
you have to go to work in a number of
scenarios
because at the end of the month you get
what's called a paycheck
which then gets you the [ __ ] car that
you like
and that car is feeding into your
insecurities it's giving you temporary
happiness
and it's giving you temporary happiness
because it's it's numbing a block that
you're not willing
to address which could come from a
previous subconscious behavior
you don't have to go to work tomorrow
nobody has to go to work tomorrow
you choose to so when i'm in trouble
i chose to be here the other thing is
and i think it's there's a few other
things as well is that
this is the moment so a lot of the time
we'll get i wish i wasn't here always i
was on the beach
you have to go you mentioned marcus
aurelius you have to go a little bit
stoic you have to look at
creating presents you have to everyone's
tried
uh headspace this year or calm or
whatever for sure
like eighty percent of the people
listening to podcasts have definitely
tried it
and and probably 90 have stopped already
because they don't need
it but you have to get in the moment
and this is something that's totally
lost
because the first thing we do when we
face adversity
is we try and leave the moment we try
and
go back i wish i was still on the beach
or we try and go i can't wait till i've
gone on the beach again
and that's what i was doing in that
hospital bed until i went back to sleep
and woke up and looked at myself and
said what can i do right now
now i'm in the moment i'm me i'm with my
hand i'm going backwards and i'm going
forwards
presence is absolute key another thing
is just
smile like honestly mate
the power look at the research
the power of a smile is just
insane and okay sometimes we have to cry
but a lot of times after crying we start
to smile
look at people that cry when we get them
out of it
how do we get them out of crying we tell
them jokes we make light
and then people start crying and
laughing it's really really powerful
so i think they're they're probably
choice
presence and fun or smile are probably
my three
and they always kind of have been made
you know i think
i just haven't really like holly gets
upset with me sometimes she goes are you
excited about doing a holiday tomorrow
like yeah i'm excited but holy [ __ ]
i've still got 12 hours of today to live
and epic [ __ ] can happen right now
you know what i mean and i'm like wait
i'm excited for today i'm excited to sit
here with you
i was excited to wake up i'm excited to
go to the next meeting that i've got
i'm excited that tonight you know i'm
excited for all these things
but right now i'm not thinking about
tonight
i have to be here and it's fun
you know and i think i think a lot of
the time
this is because we're not fully happy in
what we're doing
and we're having you know i mean in a
nice way
i get asked to do different things with
different people and most of the time
like you know i can't say yes to
everything
why did i suddenly say yes to you
because i just felt it was right and
then when you say yes
you commit 100 and we're all in
and we're here and we're gonna make this
the best hour and i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
if i'd have turned up and
like luckily i checked out your podcast
listen listen to the one with
um seth he's one of my heroes you know
and i'm like this guy's gonna be cool
but even if i i've got an hour of my
life here no matter if you're a good
dude or not
i control if i want to and i have to
have the confidence to control it
i'm going to have a good time in this
hour if you're an absolute douche bag or
if you're
you're turning out to be a nice guy but
you know what i mean
we control it and people are not taking
the ownership
because people are going to dinner with
[ __ ] they don't like they're hanging
out with people that don't make their
lives better they only make it worse
because that's what society says it goes
back to what you said
and i know we we're sort of wrapping
around here but it's
totally true we're going out and hanging
out with people that we don't actually
even like
one of the things i've been thinking
about this year is
the reason that people go and do big
things
i say that as someone who's just taken a
trip out to dubai and is on the 25th
floor of dubai marina
but i think one of the reasons that
people do big
impressive events they book a trip away
to somewhere that's grand
they decide to buy a new car they do
something epic
it's because it's very hard not to be
present when you have that much stimulus
yeah and one of the goals that everybody
should have
is to try and find that level of
presence without that level of stimulus
very hard though right oh absolutely
like if you're taking the same route to
work that you've taken a thousand times
before
what's the reason for you to be present
you know that tree you know that
like uh ford mondeo with the dent in the
side of it
you know that like guy with that dog
like you know all of this stuff
and sam harris has this beautiful quote
where he says that
what most of life is
is giving our minds a reason to be here
in the present moment
that's what we should be aiming to do in
life yeah giving yourself a good enough
reason to be
here in the present moment now
you could do that by jumping out of a
plane yeah that's one of the attractions
i think of extreme sports
also probably one of the attractions of
people that are into
bondage there's this famous dominatrix
who says nothing captures attention like
a whip
and you think like if if you want to get
someone's attention slap them yeah for
one or two seconds after that you're
thinking of nothing else
yeah i'm sure that as you the this
moment in between hitting the truck and
hitting the wall at 54 kilometers an
hour
i'm sure that that dilated out to feel
like an eternity and you can delve back
into that
so quickly because it's such an extreme
event yes but the goal is to try and
find that level of presence in everyday
life and it's again the armchair
philosophizing can go on for forever
but the point is that there are things
in the present moment we can find that
make us feel happy
that make us feel fulfilled that make us
feel connected with other people
and the more that we're masking over
that with
[ __ ] friends with nights out we don't
even enjoy
with hobbies that haven't been relevant
for five years because if we leave them
we're not going to have the same support
structure
um and it's one of the advantages
conversely to something that maybe
sounded like a weakness earlier where
you were like well
you know i i struggled necessarily to
connect with as many people as you might
think
yeah the advantage of that is it makes
you a lot more agile and flexible to do
just what you want
without the influence of other people
yeah um so again
it's interesting how it all maps on yeah
i wanted to talk about
self-doubt yeah you don't sound like the
sort of person that has
doubts when they come up how do you deal
with them i think self-doubt
is a product of thoughts and behaviors
so why are you getting self-doubt
because you think that you can't do
something
so thought behavior is the doing
something
why are we getting that why are we
getting in that situation is it because
something that's happened in our past
or is it because of something actually
real
and what example can we use but
i don't really have one off my head but
the point is is that
okay you're going into interview and
we've heard people go into like how many
people go to an interview and they're
like
i'm ready for this i'm gonna absolutely
[ __ ] smash this and i'm probably
going to get this job
almost no one no one how are you before
you're into it yeah
i'm a bit nervous um well i've applied
for the job and
and the jobs to drive a tractor and i've
only driven a scooter before
okay well that so that is we don't have
the behavior to get that so self-doubt
comes in so sometimes it's
it's real because we're we're signing up
for something
that the task we don't have the skill
set for
but we don't have the skill set for it
yet
when i started ultra running i didn't
have the skill set for ultra running the
most i'd run
was like marathons but i wanted to
develop that skill set
and i knew i could develop that skill
set over time and i knew it was a
learning experience
at the start was there self-doubt i
don't think so mate i've never
suffered really from self-doubt because
i think i've always had
confidence because probably because of
the way that i was brought up
i understand that a lot of people were
brought up different from how i was
brought up and a lot of people have been
told
no a number of times and that brings in
self-doubt if we go back to what's
important here is how can we
eliminate self-doubt is by training it
we have to put in things that if you
want to drive the truck and you can only
drive a scooter
then start upgrading your skill set and
then your doubt and your confidence is
going to come
and there's certain it's like when we
get people in that want to lose weight
there's certain people that want to go
cold turkey and they're happy to you
know we can drop five kilos off you in a
month
and there's certain people that okay i'm
not just willing to give up that quite
yet
no worries and that's fine we can give
up
dairy we can remove sugar we can remove
soft drinks but you can keep your
chocolate
and this is what people don't understand
when it comes to health
weight loss nutrition is that you don't
have to go to cold turkey
you don't have to today drive a scooter
and tomorrow and go for truck driving
lessons you can go from a scooter to a
car to a vista or that or to the other
there's different routes we can go based
on what's gonna
make you feel comfortably uncomfortable
so it's still gonna push you out the
comfort zone
do i get do i sign up for things do i
commit to things and sometimes
wonder if i can achieve it yes
absolutely mate
again i don't think that's i would lie
if i said no
because then what's the point in signing
up to things does
300k from the top of general jace to my
gym
do i think [ __ ] there's a chance that i
could fail at this
yeah there's a legitimate chance
but i'm gonna do everything that i can
that the first 10k
is literally 20 downhill there's no path
it's carnage mate and the time that
we're gonna start to the time that we
want to finish it's going to be pitch
black
there's absolute real chance
that within the first 100 meters i can
trip over a rock fall break my leg and
the whole thing's over
and everything that i've told you that
i'm going to do it on the show i'm going
to tell all the other media that i've
trained that i've
woken up early that i've left my wife on
our own i've sacrificed my business
time on my business i've sacrificed time
with relationships it's all gone in 100
meters
but when i was coming here this morning
i could have got stuck in the lift
but i didn't think about that so
we kind of why would we we control
i got in the lift i press the button i
i'm done if the lift breaks when i'm on
the 24th of 25 floors
that's it i've done all of the training
i've got all of my equipment right
i set off at the time i go on the pace i
go on the track
and then i keep going why would i worry
about it
we're worrying about things that we
can't control like this is very stoic at
the same time mate very very story you
know and the more
it's it's funny because three or four
years ago
i started sort of reading more about
stoicisms and stoicism and it's sort of
really started to resonate with me and
then you know
daily stoic podcast as well and and then
you know
ross's ageless stoic sports science far
out this is like
it all just stuff that but is it is it
the stoicism
or is that just a way of human behavior
that they found that they wrote about
that we find about being present you
know
focusing on what you can control and
putting all of your energy into what you
can control
will remove self-doubt you're only going
to doubt stuff if you're not confident
in the plan and the decision-making
process
i make bad decisions mate i've made a
load of bad decisions
but we made decisions in that time
based on a decision-making process have
i since
tweaked that decision-making process
based around certain situations
absolutely i think that's learning and
may i'm
i'm turning 42 next month i'm still
super young
i'm still trying to figure [ __ ] out and
whether my [ __ ] really works or not
but at the same time i don't think i
think self-doubt
comes from issues that we we're not
addressing
in the correct way and why are we not
mate
because we come everything we've spoken
about all these different angles that
we've kind of gone through on this show
we kind of come to the same thing that a
lot of this
could be based on subconscious behavior
from our past
that sometimes is really hard to address
the more i learn about motivation i work
with people in performance in really
tough situations tonight i'm going to
take a guy to the middle of the desert
at 6 pm
and he's gonna run for 24 hours non-stop
wow and he's gonna learn [ __ ] that he's
never learned before
he's gonna have moments that parts of
his childhood
and behavior and with his relationship
with his wife with his kids with his
parents
he's going to start to come and [ __ ]
with his mind it's going to be an
insane experience for him but he's going
to bring
that behavior maybe not definitely
right up here and get it out
it's really hard mate and that's why
people are unable to achieve great
things a lot of the time that's when we
have self-doubt confidence we have a
victim mindset
because we've not dealt with things in
the right way
and it's tragic you mentioned your
buddy who's about to run 24 hours you've
done a variety of different
endurance events as well is there a
particular point
that you could identify as the most
discomfort you've been in during them
every event's different right
this time last year i was running around
a 400 meter track
i did that for 24 hours and
it was about it's quite a weird story
this one right
but there's humor to it and then there's
some quite serious heart
it was about 11 a.m i started at 3 p.m
it was 11 a.m the next day it was
getting hot
when he comes the gut microbiome changes
i was incredibly fortunate that i had a
lot of people that were running with me
the whole time around the track i think
i only did like two laps on my own
so and some of these people i didn't
really know them very well
so which i shouldn't have done and this
is so
like not like me but i didn't feel that
it was right
to fart in front of them
[Laughter]
so mate literally i'm [ __ ] i'm i'm
18 hours around the track and
when you're doing physical activity and
you're taking on different foods and
caffeine gels and
it's not healthy mate your guts are in a
mess
and i'm not able to fart and i got to a
point where
where tom tom walker who who works with
me
and and and helps me on a lot these
things he's a he's a very intelligent
sport scientist so
when we want to get geeky we go into
stuff he was running with me and i said
i said mate you've got to get rid of
these people
he's like mate people have come for you
and i'm like
well mate i'm literally about to [ __ ]
myself
so he says to the people he says can you
give him
20 meters and he just needs a bit of
space
and honestly mate there are some
fantastic human beings
on the planet in my life and and i am
genuinely grateful
they all just said yes and they just
backed off and i'm literally just
farting like
but they're running downstream of you
they're running yeah it's disastrous
you should have said go ahead of me 20
meters and
i'm obviously incredibly fatigued i've
done about 180 100.
some about 180k let's say and
this pain in my gut was getting worse
when i was farting and i said to tom i
said mate this is this is not really
helping
and it was getting hot as well it was
about 30 degrees we had everything it's
quite it's quite
good for dubai i mean it rained
it was cold like one point i was running
in a long sleeve and then it was getting
hot towards midday
and i said i said mate i need to go we
need to go to the toilet
and he was like well of course we can go
to the toilet but i got in this sort of
tunnel vision that i just had to keep
running
and anyway i'd gone to the toilet and
literally i went in the toilet mate and
i've got my sunglasses and my cap on
no shirt and i dropped my shorts and i'm
sat on the toilet
and everything's come out and i'm in
this incredible amount of pain
my legs are [ __ ] like completely
running on a track is just
it's just the same motion over and over
and
i'm [ __ ] myself and i look around
and i see
the butt hoes which is very common here
the butt hoes you don't have much in the
uk
i'm just like and i start having a
shower
i don't like my legs are killing and i'm
like
i didn't know where i was i was just in
this
i was just in this insane
state of
pain of just pure
joy of everything because i knew i was
getting better i was getting cooler and
and tom knocked on the door i know it
was three minutes later or five minutes
later he goes
you okay in there mate oh
yeah and then i realized
i was there to run and i put the butt
hoes down and i pulled up my shorts i'm
dripping wet through water everywhere i
don't even know if my ass was clean and
i just got up and i just went out to the
track
and i carried on running incredibly slow
for the last two or three hours
why do i share that mate is because
this is an incredible experience on so
many different levels
there's so many different moving parts
there's
not wanting to let people down there's
am i embarrassed why do i care
there's the pain that i'm going through
then there's just getting
into this cubicle and the pictures
you've all just
thought through some of you're a bit
more scarred than others of this
man laying back on a toilet like half on
almost like you'd find
someone drunk in a nightclub or
something dare i say it
just showering with a butt hoes and it's
literally
one of the most amazing moments of my
life because
everything is coming together i'm i'm so
[ __ ] alive right now
and that's what these events do mate
they they
cause you to go into such a
an unusual situation hallucinations
pain call it what you will make and
then you just and had it you go in the
sahara
and i just walk around the corner where
it feels like a corner there's really
nice corners in the sahara
and you just look up and you're like
[ __ ]
i'm a human and this is earth and i'm
running across this [ __ ] sahara
desert
and it's amazing it's like you're reborn
mate
and i was in kenya last year in hell
literally in helmet i've got chafe and
there's a picture of me
i this race was self-supported so i'm
carrying everything
and it's awful and it's hot and then i
find a picture on my gopro
and i'm next to a [ __ ] giraffe
is this real like if i was fighting
which i was fighting the pain but then
you're just reborn
just through a giraffe and this is one
of the
the the things that we haven't touched
on which i just think is super important
the power of the planet of nature
of animals of plants of sunrises
of the circadian rhythm is absolutely
incredible
it's hard for me to explain pain and
suffering
because i think it's different for
everyone and
i can we could do a whole hour
about the pain i've been in but it's
irrelevant
i chose to be there but the lessons from
it
and the amazing things that
ultra has given me that human beings has
given me
that allow me to be present that allow
me to live i really think is what
contributes to wanting to wake up
early every single morning before my
alarm some days
some days on my alarm mate some days i'm
like what the [ __ ]
you know i'm the same as everyone like
bang
and just get up and live and overcome
those tough things of
you know i don't feel 100 today and
that's why i do this stuff
because those situations that i've been
in
and we've all been in situations but i
chose to be there and i've unpicked
those situations
and i thought about the track one is
really
i don't think i fully understood it yet
it's only a year on
and you know there's so many moving
parts there's what tom did there was the
time in the cubicle there's the people
there's so many different things going
along and that's what's amazing mate
i can literally sit and look at a
picture that's on my camera roll from
one of the ultras that i've done
and i'll look at it like it's the first
time i've looked at it
and these are free tools to us
we're always looking and but it's hard
because i have to relive those
situations
and that's tough because if you remember
it for the pain
but a lot of time i try and remember it
for what it's brought me
and the great tools it's brought me to
deal with life
to do i have 25 people working for me i
have relationships i have parents that i
have to deal with that are 75
and want to travel during covert you
know what i mean and there's these
different things that
you can you can take from it and one of
the most beautiful things and the thing
that i'm
i'm not one of these massive hashtag
grateful thankful
gratitude people but i do have an
incredible amount of gratitude
and i think i don't need to show it off
on on instagram with people but
through having these opportunities to do
these challenges
i'm able to the guy that's gonna
we've got a few guys running long
tonight i'm able to
share that with him and then watch him
and his relationships and his life grow
and that
is one of the most incredible things
i've got somehow this gift
that i can help someone do something
better i'm not
tony robbins i can't change a thousand
people at once
but i can take him and i can he's gonna
be in hell
he's going to address some things and
tomorrow night at 6 00 pm when he stops
running and he has a cold beer
he's going to be reborn right and it's
literally there's a there's a picture
and it's one of my it's my favorite
picture of 2019
i can't say it's my favorite picture of
the decade but it's one of my favorite
pictures of 2019
where at the end of my 24 hour run i was
hugging holly
and one of my mates
sent me a message i don't know if he
wrote on the post or he sent me a
message he goes
in this situation you feel
like death but in the same
moment you feel reborn quite the
conundrum oh my
[ __ ] this is this is really it like
maybe you can see like i'm emotional
about it because that's really it
you've been in such a tough place but
now you're just so [ __ ] alive and
it's just
how do we get that more often i've never
wanted to do endurance stuff
and the last couple of days last couple
of weeks i've been listening a lot to
brian
yeah in a few weeks i've been listening
to yourself
tom otten is gonna come he's gonna be
sat where you are in a couple of hours
yeah
and i don't think i've ever heard people
talk about
endurance events in this sort of a way
yeah and
it just if there was ever a front end of
the funnel man for wanting to start
doing this i've never even wanted to run
a half marathon but i just think
wow what an opportunity for growth you
know
i released some podcasts today called
it's not about running
and honestly mate i was i didn't know
what show i was gonna put out this week
i didn't have
any guests lined up and blah blah blah
blah and i went through a lot of my old
articles
and i wrote an article in 2018 or 2019
called it's not about running and i read
it
and i was like you know what that's
actually a really good article
like pat on the back sort of thing and i
was like
you know what i can share this with
people and i can put it into a podcast
because
you said it there i've never run in half
or it's not about the running mate
i haven't talked to you about running
we've talked about life
and i don't think i definitely didn't
realize the power of ultra endurance
until i got knee-deep in it mate
i never thought how did it start is what
a lot of people ask me and honestly mate
a lady walked into my gym one day and
said i need your help
she said i'm gonna run this ultra
marathon and i was like never done one
she goes no i just wanted to help me on
my strength and nutrition i said i could
do that
i said would you mind if i learn i see
because i find it difficult to tell
someone to do so i haven't done
and that's what started it in 2009 and
it's incredible mate a lot of people
i'm so grateful again that you've
spent the time and you've understood a
little bit because a lot of people
anything over their threshold and it's
10k 5k or 21k it's all just running
but it's not it's life it's something
that's so unique mate and it's something
that's so
innate it's what we're designed to do
without trying to sell it
in endurance it's actually what we
decide designed to do
look back to our ancestors they worked
here
they got water here 10 miles away we
went
by walking or running it's only in the
last 50 years that we don't
move in the way that we're supposed to
move and that's led to all the problems
that we've got now
it's so natural for us be a hippie about
it it's what we're supposed to do
man uh you might not be trying to
advertise long distance stuff but
it's it's gassed me up and i'm sure it's
really sort of invigorated a lot of
people as well
and if ever there was a year to do it
like when your gyms have shut down
the number of people i think have taken
up distance running and hopefully
they'll have taken some of the lessons
that you've had today from their own
experience as well so man i've adored
today you've got to get on
um and i've got i need to have another
coffee i don't know what to do after
this
i don't know whether i don't know
whether i want to cry whether i want to
throw myself
off the roof into the pool whether i
need a coffee whether i need to sleep i
need something
i'll just try and keep it real mate i
appreciate you you're chatting to me
mate honestly really good questions and
as i said at the start i try and talk a
lot because i try and
share with people and get out as much as
i can because
it's i don't i don't have all the
answers mate
and i just have these experiences and i
just hope that other people will
try and find experiences are we looking
for answers i don't know but here's one
thing
that might be a nice part in insight for
you there's only a few people on the
planet that have done the things that
you've done
bizarrely there's a duty of those people
to teach everyone else about their
insights
we go to the moon we collect samples we
come back home
and people who are experienced analyze
those samples
[Music]
people who decide to push frontiers in
other areas
whether that be with meditation whether
that be with physical training
whether that be with reading and
compiling wisdom whatever
it's their job it's their duty they
are the person who knows it they are the
people who've experienced it
it's their duty to then teach the rest
of us because that's how we move forward
right
and i think that very virtuously that's
what you're spending your time doing as
well with these
events so people will want to check out
more about you
where should they go the easiest thing
is instagram mate mjd
underscore smith hit me up on there i
reply to everyone
i'm not a rude prick dig for the insta
slots
brother thank you so much thank you
amazing appreciate it that was awesome
you